I don't know about you, but you know what I think would feel great today? An animal story, and not one of those stories where the animals are some metaphor for human beings and we see ourselves through their actions and learn some important lesson.
不知道你们怎么想，但我今天觉得什么事会很棒呢？一个动物的故事，而不是那种把动物当作人类隐喻的故事，不需要让我们通过它们的行为审视自己并学到什么重要的人生课。
No, no, no, no. I'm talking about an old-fashioned animal story where you hear about some amazing creature in some surprising situation. And that creature then does things that have such personality and seems so specifically them. It just gets to you.
不，不，不。我说的是那种老派的动物故事，你会听到关于某种神奇生物在某种令人惊讶的情况下的故事。然后那个生物做出的事情具有如此独特的个性，显得如此与众不同。这真的会打动你。
I am pleased to say we have a story like that for you today. And the creature is not a dog, or a cat, or a bunny, or a horse, or any of the lovable creatures you usually find in this kind of story. It's an orca, a killer whale that we humans captured from the wild, took from his mother and trained to be completely tame and live alongside us.
我很高兴地说，今天我们为你准备了这样一个故事。而这个生物不是狗、猫、兔子、马，也不是你在这类故事中通常能看到的那些可爱生物。它是一头虎鲸，一头我们人类从野外捕获、从它母亲身边带走，并训练得完全顺从、与我们共同生活的虎鲸。
This killer whale was so tamed that at night, when his trainers went home, and he was all alone, he would watch TV from inside his tank. He liked old Andy Griffith reruns and action movies. And that continued for years, until, one day, we got the idea that maybe this killer whale didn't need to continue as a giant domesticated pet. Maybe it will be possible for him to lead a very different life in the wild again.
这头虎鲸被驯化得甚至在晚上，当训练员回家、剩下它独自一鲸时，它会从水族箱里看电视。它喜欢老片《安迪·格里菲斯秀》的重播和动作电影。这种情况持续了多年，直到有一天，我们产生了一个想法：也许这头虎鲸不需要继续做一只巨大的家养宠物了。也许它有可能在野外过上完全不同的生活。
Today's story comes from our co-workers at Serial. They, of course, have done so many remarkable series that have changed everybody's expectations of what you can do in a podcast. I have been sitting in on readthroughs of drafts of episodes of this new series for a year now. I'm one of the people who gives editing notes.
今天的故事来自我们的同事 Serial。他们当然制作了许多非凡的系列节目，改变了所有人对播客创作的预期。这一年来，我一直在参加这个新系列剧本的朗读会。我是那些提供编辑建议的人之一。
And whenever we do one of these listening sessions, I have to say it's always one of the best parts of my week. I really love this story, one of my favorite things they've ever done. This new series is called The Good Whale, six episodes long, including-- I'm not kidding-- a musical episode. Maybe I'll tell you about that later. They launched the first two episodes this week, and we're going to play you episode 1 of the show right now.
每当我们进行这样的听取会时，我不得不说，这总是我一周中最美好的时光之一。我真的很喜欢这个故事，这是他们制作过的我最喜欢的作品之一。这个新系列名为《好鲸鱼》，共有六集，包括——我没开玩笑——一集音乐剧。也许我以后会告诉你关于那一集的事。他们本周发布了前两集，我们现在就要为您播放第一集。
And then after the break, we have another story-- not from Serial, but a story that we made-- about animals and what we expect of them. From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Daniel Alarcón, the novelist and journalist and host of Radio Ambulante, is the host of this new show for Serial. And with that, I will turn things over to Daniel. Here's episode 1 of their show.
休息之后，我们还有另一个故事——不是来自 Serial，而是我们制作的故事——关于动物以及我们对它们的期望。这里是来自芝加哥 WBEZ 的《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。小说家、记者兼《Radio Ambulante》主持人丹尼尔·阿拉尔孔是 Serial 这个新节目的主持人。说到这里，我把时间交给丹尼尔。这是他们的第一集。
Our story begins in the early '90s with an orca named Keiko. He's just entering his teenage years, living at an amusement park in Mexico City called Reino Aventura, or Adventure Kingdom. He's not from there, but for the last seven years, a tank in this polluted, landlocked megacity more than 7,000 feet above sea level has been his home.
我们的故事始于 90 年代初，主角是一头名叫凯克的虎鲸。它刚进入青少年时期，生活在墨西哥城一个叫“冒险王国”的游乐园里。它不是那儿的土著，但过去七年里，这个位于海平面以上 7000 多英尺、污染严重且处于内陆的特大城市里的一个水族箱，一直是它的家。
Before that, it was a marine park in Canada, where he was bullied by the other orcas. Before that, it was a tank in a big, concrete building in Iceland, where he was kept for about three years, unable to see the sky. And even before that, it was the North Atlantic, where he was captured and separated from his mom and the rest of his whale pod, probably when he was around two.
在那之前，它住在加拿大的一家海洋公园，在那里它被其他虎鲸欺负。再之前，它住在一个冰岛的大型混凝土建筑里的水箱里，被关了大约三年，看不见天空。而在那之前，它生活在北大西洋，大概两岁时被捕获，并与它的母亲及鲸群的其他成员分开了。
I don't think I really understood how traumatic this could have been until I learned that male killer whales are essentially mama's boys, and not just when they're young, but basically their entire lives. Even as adults, they might swim by their mother's side. They depend on her. A mother orca might catch a fish, bite it in two, and give half to her son. This kind of closeness is documented in male orcas well into their 20s or 30s.
我之前没真正理解这有多么创伤，直到我了解到雄性虎鲸本质上是“妈宝”，不仅在幼年时期，几乎是终其一生。即使成年后，它们也可能游在母亲身边。它们依赖母亲。虎鲸妈妈可能会捉到一条鱼，咬成两半，分一半给儿子。这种亲密关系在 20 多岁甚至 30 多岁的雄性虎鲸身上都有记录。
And Keiko was deprived of the chance to have that. At age two, Keiko would probably still have been swimming in his mother's slipstream, still mastering the language of his pod. He wouldn't have yet learned how to hunt on his own. Despite weighing more than 1,000 pounds, in developmental terms, Keiko would have been just a baby, ripped from his mother, from everything he'd ever known and from a life that may have been largely spent by her side.
而凯克被剥夺了这种机会。两岁时，凯克本应该还在母亲的尾流中游动，继续掌握鲸群的语言。它还没学会如何独立狩猎。尽管体重超过 1000 磅，但在发育阶段，凯克本该只是个婴儿，却被从母亲身边、从它所知的一切以及它本该大部分时间待在母亲身边的生活中夺走。
So of course, it's hard to talk about a pool in a Mexican amusement park as a substitute for any of that. But what I can say is that the people who work there, they truly, sincerely love Keiko. They are, for all intents and purposes, his pod.
所以，谈论墨西哥游乐园里的一个水池作为这一切的替代品当然很困难。但我能说的是，在那里工作的人们，他们真心实意地爱着凯克。在所有实际意义上，他们就是它的鲸群。
Well, obviously, my purpose in life at that time, it was Keiko and Keiko only.
好吧，很明显，那时候我生活的目的就是凯克，只有凯克。
That's Renata Fernandez, who worked with Keiko at Reino Aventura.
那是雷娜塔·费尔南德斯，她曾在“冒险王国”与凯克一起工作。
Before having kids, he was my kid. He was my baby. I mean, I had boyfriends back then, but they were not that important as Keiko. I had to break up with two boyfriends because I spent most of my time with him. I worked there for seven years, and it was the best seven years of my life.
在有孩子之前，它就是我的孩子。我的意思是，我当时有男朋友，但他们不像凯克那么重要。我不得不和两个男朋友分手，因为我大部分时间都花在它身上。我在那儿工作了七年，那是我一生中最美好的七年。
Renata started at Reino Aventura when she was 20 years old. She chopped frozen fish, mopped the pool deck, and eventually worked her way up to be one of Keiko's trainers. Working with a killer whale had long been a dream of hers. And even now, when she talks about Keiko, she sounds the way a mother might when reminiscing about her kid's childhood. She remembers all of Keiko's favorite games, his favorite toys, his favorite playmate.
雷娜塔 20 岁时开始在“冒险王国”工作。她切冻鱼、拖地，最终晋升为凯克的训练员之一。与虎鲸一起工作一直是她的梦想。即使是现在，当她谈起凯克时，听起来就像一位母亲在回忆孩子的童年。她记得凯克所有的游戏、最喜欢的玩具和最好的玩伴。
His best friend was a dolphin named Richie. And they would just play nonstop. And between shows he would just have Richie on top of him, just kind of like giving him a ride.
它最好的朋友是一只名叫里奇的海豚。它们会不停地玩耍。在演出间隙，它会让里奇骑在它背上，就像带它兜风一样。
If Keiko had his moods or played favorites, well, Renata says, that was just part of who he was.
如果凯克闹情绪或偏爱某些人，雷娜塔说，那只是它性格的一部分。
Keiko would choose who to play with. I mean, we had this very young girl. She was 16 or 17. And she would come into the water, and it was like a magnet for Keiko. He would love her, love to be with her. And why? Nobody knows. I mean, just, it's like chemistry.
凯克会选择和谁一起玩。我的意思是，我们有一个非常年轻的女孩，她才 16 或 17 岁。她一下水，就像是凯克的磁铁。它会爱她，喜欢和她在一起。为什么？没人知道。我的意思是，这就像化学反应。
In the offseason, when there were no weekday shows at Reino Aventura, Renata and the other trainers swam and played with Keiko for hours. Most of the people who worked with Keiko were young, none older than 30, and they made Keiko the center of their lives. They fed him by hand, gave him belly rubs all the time. They even set up a special hose just for him. He loved to be sprayed. And as far as anyone could tell, Keiko genuinely seemed to like it.
在淡季，“冒险王国”没有工作日演出时，雷娜塔和其他训练员会和凯克游泳、玩耍几个小时。和凯克一起工作的大多数人都很年轻，没有超过 30 岁的，他们把凯克变成了生活的中心。他们用手喂它，一直给它挠肚子。他们甚至专门为它安装了一根软管。它喜欢被喷水。据大家所知，凯克真心喜欢那样。
We had this little boat, and there was a rope tied to the front, like a long rope. But we would put it in the water, and three girls would hop in it. And he would pull us all over the pool, and then he would pull it down, just to make us fall from the boat. And that was over and over. And obviously, we would laugh and then get on top of the little boat again. He would give us a ride again. So, I mean, he would have a blast.
我们有一艘小船，前面系着一根绳子，很长的绳子。我们会把它放进水里，三个女孩跳上去。它会拉着我们绕水池转，然后它会把船拽下去，就为了让我们掉进水里。这不断重复。很明显，我们会笑，然后又爬上小船。它会再次载我们。所以，我的意思是，它玩得非常开心。
There's nothing about that last sentence of Renata's that could be fact-checked, not a word. We don't know if Keiko was having a blast. We can't know.
雷娜塔的最后一句话没有任何事实依据，一个字都没有。我们不知道凯克是否玩得开心。我们无法得知。
Maybe he was dragging the trainers around because he was bored or because he loved these friendly people who fed him every day. Maybe what his humans interpreted as Keiko having fun was really just habit-- or even defeat. Like, why not let the people ride? They seem to like it.
也许它拖着训练员跑是因为无聊，或者因为它喜欢这些每天给它喂食的友好的人。也许人类解读为凯克在享受乐趣，实际上只是习惯——甚至是一种屈服。比如，为什么不让这些人搭车呢？他们看起来很喜欢。
We can't really know what animals are thinking, so we do our best with the information we have, making educated guesses about the inner lives of the creatures we love. And that's what this story is really about-- an imperfect attempt to understand what might be best for an animal who can't speak for himself, the intention to make things right for him, to make things better.
我们无法真正了解动物在想什么，所以我们尽最大努力利用现有信息，对我们所爱的生物的内心世界进行有根据的猜测。这就是这个故事的真正意义所在——一种不完美的尝试，试图了解对一个无法为自己发声的动物来说什么是最好的，意图把事情做对，让事情变得更好。
Everything I'm going to tell you is set in motion by these good intentions. And by everything, I mean an unprecedented global campaign, a high-profile, high-stakes science experiment, and a debate about what exactly we humans owe the natural world.
我要告诉你的一切都是由这些善意引发的。我说的“一切”是指一场史无前例的全球运动、一场高调且风险巨大的科学实验，以及一场关于我们人类到底欠自然界什么的辩论。
At the center of it all is Keiko, who would become, almost by accident, a symbol for all whales, for the health of the oceans, for the very concept of wildness, but who was also an individual orca with a name, and specific history, and trauma, and character, a character with fears and limitations that no human could ever hope to interpret with any certainty-- not that they wouldn't try. In fact, lots of well-intentioned people would claim they knew exactly what was best for this whale. And they would be arguing and fighting over those interpretations for years.
这一切的核心是凯克，它几乎是偶然地成为了所有鲸鱼的象征，成为海洋健康和野性概念本身的象征，但它同时也是一只拥有名字、特定历史、创伤和性格的虎鲸，一个有着任何人类都无法确切解读的恐惧和局限的个体——并不是说他们不会尝试。事实上，许多心怀善意的人都会声称他们最了解这头鲸鱼。而他们会在这些解读上争吵和斗争多年。
It wasn't just Renata and the other trainers who loved Keiko, or even just the people in Mexico City who went to see Keiko at Reino Aventura. It seems like pretty much every kid in Mexico knew him. He was beloved, a kind of national mascot.
不仅仅是雷娜塔和其他训练员爱凯克，甚至不仅仅是墨西哥城去看凯克的人爱它。似乎墨西哥几乎每个孩子都知道它。它备受喜爱，是一种国家吉祥物。
He was like the pet, Mexico's pet.
它就像宠物，墨西哥的宠物。
One person I spoke to compared him to a Mexican Mickey Mouse. And in fact, a lot of people assumed that Keiko was Mexican, like actually from Mexico. They never considered that he could have come from anywhere else. He was just theirs.
我交谈过的一个人把它比作墨西哥的米老鼠。事实上，许多人认为凯克是墨西哥鲸，也就是真正来自墨西哥。他们从未考虑过它可能来自其他地方。它就是他们的。
We talked to lots of people who grew up in Mexico City in the '80s and '90s, and they said again and again that Keiko had an aura about him, that seeing him at Reino Aventura was like hanging out with your 7,000-pound best friend, the killer whale you told your secrets to-- what was happening at school, who your crush was. It was that kind of relationship.
我们和许多在 80 年代和 90 年代在墨西哥城长大的年轻人谈过，他们反复说凯克身上有一种光环，在“冒险王国”看它就像和你的 7000 磅重的好朋友待在一起，那个你可以倾诉秘密的虎鲸——学校里发生了什么，你暗恋谁。就是那种关系。
If you watched television in Mexico in the late '80s or early '90s, chances were that sooner or later, you'd see Keiko. He was in Reino Aventura commercials, of course. There were pop songs dedicated to him.
如果你在 80 年代末或 90 年代初看墨西哥电视，你很有可能会看到凯克。它当然出现在“冒险王国”的广告里。还有专门为它创作的流行歌曲。
[SINGING IN SPANISH]
[西班牙语演唱]
He even starred in a telenovela as himself.
它甚至以自己的身份出演了一部肥皂剧。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
And then there were the shows, when visitors got to see their beloved pet up close. Reino Aventura doesn't exist anymore-- not under that name anyway. It's since been acquired by Six Flags. But back in its heyday, in the early '90s, Keiko was the star attraction. And these shows, they were legendary.
还有表演，游客们可以近距离观看他们心爱的宠物。“冒险王国”现在已经不存在了——至少名字不是那个了。后来被六旗游乐园收购。但在它鼎盛时期的 90 年代初，凯克是招牌景点。而这些表演非常传奇。
At the peak of his fame, there might have been 200 people lining up a couple of hours before the gates opened. A pair of clowns marched around, playing trumpets, entertaining Keiko's fans as they filed in. On weekends, there were three shows a day, more than 3,000 seats consistently packed. I had Renata walk me through one of the routines. First it was the sea lions, then the dolphins, including Richie. And then--
在它名气最旺的时候，大门开启前会有 200 人排队。一对小丑吹着小号在周围走动，在凯克的粉丝进场时娱乐他们。周末每天有三场演出，超过 3000 个座位总是座无虚席。我让雷娜塔带我走了一遍表演流程。首先是海狮，然后是海豚，包括里奇。接着——
We would open the pen, and Keiko would come out jumping.
我们会打开围栏，凯克会跳出来。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
[AUDIENCE SQUEALING, CHEERING]
[观众尖叫、欢呼]
So the people would just go crazy, obviously. So that was the show. And after that, all the trainers would come out and go greet people and take pictures with people.
人们当然会疯狂。表演就是这样。之后，所有的训练员会出来和观众打招呼并合影。
There were so many people clamoring to see Keiko up close that his veterinarian told me they set up a kind of receiving line. He even compared the crowds to the believers who wait in line to see the Virgin of Guadalupe-- that reverential, that devoted.
有太多人吵着要近距离看凯克，它的兽医告诉我，他们设置了一条接待线。他甚至把人群比作排队看瓜达卢佩圣母像的信徒——那样虔诚，那样专注。
So that's Keiko, occasional TV star, quasi saint, telepathic confidante, and best friend to countless Mexican children. And this was his life-- constant attention from his trainers, games with his favorite dolphin buddies, performances for thousands of adoring fans. But it was all about to change.
这就是凯克，偶尔的电视明星、准圣人、心灵感应的知己，以及无数墨西哥孩子最好的朋友。这就是它的生活——来自训练员的持续关注、与海豚好友的游戏、为数千名崇拜粉丝表演。但这一切都即将改变。
In 1992, Reino Aventura was set to close for some much-needed renovations, which meant Keiko had some free time-- six months with no shows and no crowds. So when a production company proposed to film a movie with Keiko, the park's director, Oscar Porter, thought, what the hell? Why not? It wasn't much money, but it might keep Keiko entertained.
1992 年，“冒险王国”准备关闭进行急需的翻新，这意味着凯克有了一些空闲时间——六个月没有演出，没有人群。所以当一家制作公司提议和凯克拍电影时，公园负责人奥斯卡·波特想，管他呢？为什么不呢？虽然钱不多，但也许能让凯克消遣一下。
Once he said yes to the movie, Porter didn't give it much more thought. He was busy overseeing all the details of the park's upgrades, the installation of new rides, new contracts with vendors, more than 600 employees. He told me he didn't even read the script.
一旦答应了电影，波特就没再多想。他忙于监督公园升级的所有细节、安装新游乐设施、与供应商签署新合同，还有管理 600 多名员工。他告诉我他甚至没读剧本。
But that script is why we're telling you the story, why you probably already know who Keiko is, even if it's by a different name. The studio behind this proposal was the American movie powerhouse, Warner Brothers. And Keiko was about to get the name you might know him by-- Willy, Free Willy.
但那个剧本就是我们讲述这个故事的原因，为什么你可能已经知道凯克是谁，即使名字不同。这个提议背后的制片厂是美国电影巨头华纳兄弟。凯克即将得到你可能熟悉的名字——威利，《人鱼的童话》。
You can do it. You can be free.
你可以做到。你可以自由。
[WATER SPLASHING]
[水花声]
If you're my age-- mid 40s-- you've probably seen the movie. But if not, or it's been a minute, here's a quick refresher. Lauren Shuler Donner, one of the producers, told me the movie could be boiled down to this-- bad kid, bad whale. The bad kid is a moody 12-year-old named Jesse.
如果你和我这个年纪——40 多岁——你可能看过这部电影。但如果没有，或者已经很久没看了，这里快速回顾一下。制片人之一劳伦·舒勒·唐纳告诉我，这部电影可以概括为：坏孩子，坏鲸鱼。坏孩子是一个名叫杰西的 12 岁忧郁男孩。
You're the graffiti kid, aren't you?
你就是那个搞涂鸦的孩子，对吧？
I guess.
我想是吧。
The bad whale is Willy, captured and separated from his pod, stuck in a small pool in a ramshackle aquarium. The park staff find him stubborn, hard to train. He has three black spots on the underside of his jaw. His dorsal fin droops to one side, a killer whale's version of an emo haircut. Jesse decides he has to save Willy's life, get him back to the ocean, back to his family, and somehow, against all kinds of obstacles, he does.
坏鲸鱼是威利，被捕获并与鲸群分离，困在一家破旧水族馆的小水池里。公园员工觉得它固执，难以训练。它的下颚下方有三个黑点。它的背鳍向一侧下垂，就像虎鲸版的忧郁发型。杰西决定拯救威利的生命，把它送回大海，回到家人身边，而且以某种方式，克服了各种障碍，他做到了。
Come on, Willy. I know you can do it, boy. I know you can jump this wall! Come on. I believe in you, Willy. You can do it. You can be free. Come on. Jump it.
来吧，威利。我知道你能做到，伙计。我知道你能跳过这道墙！来吧。我相信你，威利。你能做到的。你可以自由。来吧。跳过去。
The movie poster is what most people remember. It's the image that was absorbed into the culture, a still from the film's climax-- Willy in mid-flight against an orange sunset, jumping over a breakwater. The ocean beckons. The boy stands just below Willy, beneath an arc of sea spray, a triumphant arm pointing to the sky. The tagline reads, "How far would you go for a friend?"
电影海报是大多数人记忆最深的部分。那是被文化吸收的图像，电影高潮时的剧照——威利在橘色日落背景下飞跃防波堤。海洋在召唤。男孩站在威利下方，在水雾弧线下，一只胜利的手指向天空。宣传语写着：“你会为朋友走多远？”
Yeah!
耶！
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
When it came to who would play Willy, it wasn't like Warner Brothers had a ton of killer whales to choose from. A producer on the film told us her team approached a few different marine parks, but people weren't excited about the message of the movie and wanted changes to the script.
说到由谁来演威利，华纳兄弟并没有多少虎鲸可供选择。电影的一位制片人告诉我们，她的团队接触了几家不同的海洋公园，但人们对电影要传达的信息并不兴奋，并希望更改剧本。
Finally, they landed on Reino Aventura, who signed off, as we mentioned, without even reading it. And Keiko, it turns out, was perfect for the part. See, for the film to work, the producers needed something very specific, a kind of sad-looking whale living in less than ideal conditions. They needed a whale kids would feel sorry for, a whale children would want to save.
最后，他们找到了“冒险王国”，正如我们提到的，他们在没读剧本的情况下签了名。事实证明，凯克非常适合这个角色。你看，为了让电影成功，制片人需要一些非常具体的东西，一种生活在不理想条件下的看起来很悲伤的鲸鱼。他们需要一种孩子们会同情、想要拯救的鲸鱼。
And the fact is, while Keiko might have been happy, he wasn't actually that healthy. He was a couple thousand pounds underweight, not because he was underfed, but probably because the warm water affected his appetite. He had a skin rash, too, something called papillomavirus, which looked bad, even though the veterinarian at Reino Aventura said it wasn't that serious.
事实是，虽然凯克可能很快乐，但它实际上并不那么健康。它体重不足几千磅，不是因为喂养不足，而是可能因为水温影响了胃口。它还有皮疹，一种叫乳头状瘤病毒的东西，看起来很糟糕，尽管“冒险王国”的兽医说这并不严重。
But most striking of all was his tank. It was small, disturbingly small. One of the film's producers joked it was smaller than some swimming pools in Beverly Hills. The water he swam in wasn't even seawater, just fresh water with salt added. Renata says they checked the salt levels frequently, and they weren't under any illusions that Keiko's living conditions were ideal. She told me Reino Aventura looked into building a larger pool, but just couldn't make it work financially.
但最引人注目的是它的水箱。它很小，小得令人不安。电影的一位制片人开玩笑说，它比比佛利山庄的一些游泳池还小。它游的水甚至不是海水，只是加了盐的淡水。雷娜塔说他们经常检查盐度，他们并没有幻想凯克的生活条件是理想的。她告诉我，“冒险王国”考虑过建造一个更大的水池，但财务上无法实现。
So strip away for a moment almost everything I've told you. Forget the love and the games and the trainers and the fans and see instead what the camera sees-- Keiko, a smaller-than-average killer whale with a droopy dorsal fin swimming alone in a tiny, shallow pool. He was exactly what the movie required.
所以，暂时抛开我告诉你的几乎一切。忘掉那些爱、游戏、训练员和粉丝，看看摄像机看到的东西——凯克，一只背鳍下垂、身材瘦小的虎鲸，独自游在一个微小、浅薄的水池里。它正是电影所需要的。
Free Willy was released on July 16, 1993, and the reviews were positive, at least until journalists started asking what was up with the star of the movie. And news reports about Keiko's subpar living conditions and health began spreading.
《人鱼的童话》于 1993 年 7 月 16 日上映，评价是积极的，直到记者开始询问电影明星的情况。关于凯克糟糕生活条件和健康的报道开始传播。
The movie Free Willy has a great ending, but real life didn't treat the real star of the box office hit the way it treated Willy in the movie. Not at all.
《人鱼的童话》有一个伟大的结局，但现实生活并没有像电影对待威利那样对待这位票房冠军的真正主角。一点也没有。
News tonight that will surely upset all those children who saw the movie Free Willy this summer. The whale that starred in the movie is sick and may die unless his living conditions are improved.
今晚的消息肯定会让所有在夏天看过《人鱼的童话》的孩子们感到难过。电影里的那头鲸鱼病了，如果生活条件不改善，它可能会死。
Soon enough, Keiko had gone from Mexico's beloved pet to Mexico's dying orca. And kids around the world were not happy.
很快，凯克就从墨西哥心爱的宠物变成了墨西哥垂死的虎鲸。全世界的孩子们都不高兴了。
I'm writing this letter to ask you to consider helping the killer whale, Keiko, in Mexico.
我写这封信是为了请求你们考虑帮助墨西哥的那头虎鲸凯克。
We would like everybody to donate $1, and we'd get lots of money so we can try to help save this whale.
我们希望每个人都捐 1 美元，我们会筹集到很多钱，这样我们就能尝试救救这头鲸鱼。
Here, this whale that people have made millions off of, and now he's just sitting in this tank, dying.
这头人们已经从中赚了数百万美元的鲸鱼，现在它只能坐在水箱里，慢慢死去。
I don't think Keiko deserves to die.
我不认为凯克应该死。
In Mexico, Reino Aventura and the staff were suddenly having to defend themselves in ways they hadn't before, trying to convince crusading celebrities and animal rights activists that they did, indeed, care about Keiko's well-being. When Life Magazine published an article describing Keiko's tank as a "cesspool," Reino Aventura's director, Oscar Porter, sent a letter claiming the magazine had gotten it all wrong, that Keiko's water was, quote, "clean and clear."
在墨西哥，“冒险王国”和员工们突然不得不以以前没有过的方式为自己辩护，试图说服发起运动的名人和动物权利活动家，他们确实关心凯克的福祉。《生活》杂志发表文章称凯克的水箱是“污水池”时，游乐园负责人奥斯卡·波特写信声称杂志搞错了，凯克的水“干净清澈”。
Back in Hollywood, Warner Brothers was getting hammered, too. Bags and bags of mail from kids arrived at the offices, all demanding the same thing-- free Willy, or rather, free Keiko. And so if the studio wanted to avoid a PR nightmare and not break the hearts of millions of children, then it was clear-- someone had to save him in real life.
在好莱坞，华纳兄弟也受到了重压。装满孩子来信的袋子送到了办公室，全都要求同一件事——释放威利，或者说是释放凯克。所以如果制片厂想避免公关噩梦，不想伤透数百万孩子的心，那么很明显——必须有人在现实生活中拯救它。
Daniel Alarcón. That's after the break, when our program continues.
丹尼尔·阿拉尔孔。那是休息之后，节目继续。
It's This American Life. We pick up the story of Keiko where we left off. Here's Daniel Alarcón.
这是《美国生活》。我们继续讲述凯克的故事。这里是丹尼尔·阿拉尔孔。
For centuries, we humans hunted and killed whales as if their numbers were infinite. And over time, we got better and better at it, more efficient, more ruthless, extracting more value from each kill. We harvested their blubber, their organs, their baleen, their meat, and it was all transformed into everyday commercial products, from makeup to heating oil. More than 700,000 whales were killed in the 1960s. Whaling was a huge global industry, with profits to match.
几个世纪以来，我们人类猎杀鲸鱼，仿佛它们的数量是无限的。随着时间推移，我们在这方面越来越擅长，效率更高，更无情，从每一次猎杀中榨取更多价值。我们收获它们的脂肪、器官、鲸须、肉，这一切都被转化为日常商业产品，从化妆品到取暖油。60 年代有超过 70 万头鲸鱼被杀。捕鲸是一个巨大的全球产业，利润与之相当。
The killing of orcas was a little different since they didn't have much to offer us, commercially speaking. But humans being humans, we killed them anyway-- for fear, for sport, for bloodlust. Fishermen trawling for herring or salmon saw them as competitors, so they would shoot them on sight. The US Navy would use orca pods for target practice. All told, it's estimated that some 3 million individual whales were killed by humans in the 20th century.
捕杀虎鲸有点不同，因为从商业角度看，它们没什么可提供给我们的。但作为人类，我们还是杀了它们——出于恐惧、为了运动、为了嗜血。渔民在捕鲱鱼或鲑鱼时视它们为竞争对手，所以他们一见到就射杀。美国海军会用虎鲸群进行目标练习。总而言之，据估计 20 世纪人类捕杀了约 300 万头鲸鱼。
By the early 1970s, scientists understood that whales were far more scarce than we'd all previously thought and began warning that the steep declines they were seeing in wild populations might be irreversible. In response, the Save the Whales movement was born, with the goal of ending commercial whaling worldwide, a bold, quixotic idea to convince the countries that still practiced whaling to simply stop.
到了 70 年代初，科学家们明白鲸鱼比我们之前认为的要稀少得多，并开始警告说，他们观察到的野生种群急剧下降可能是不可逆转的。作为回应，“拯救鲸鱼”运动诞生了，目标是结束全球范围内的商业捕鲸，这是一个大胆、堂吉诃德式的想法，旨在说服那些仍在捕鲸的国家直接停止。
I'm telling you all this because in a way, everything that happens to Keiko a couple of decades later is a result of it, of this idea that these creatures were worth protecting. And it's also when this next significant person in Keiko's life enters the story, a guy by the name of Dave Phillips.
我告诉你们这一切是因为，在某种程度上，几十年后发生在凯克身上的一切都是这一想法的结果，即这些生物值得保护。这也是凯克生命中下一个重要人物登场的时候，一个叫戴夫·菲利普斯的人。
I was pretty young then. I was like two years out of college.
那时我相当年轻。我刚大学毕业两年。
It was the late '70s. The Save the Whales campaign was just starting to pick up steam, and Dave wanted in. So he packed up his life, drove his turquoise Volkswagen Rabbit out to California, and soon joined the movement to do his part.
那是 70 年代末，“拯救鲸鱼”运动才刚开始升温，戴夫想加入。于是他打包行李，开着他的绿松石色大众 Rabbit 去了加州，很快就加入了这项运动，贡献自己的一份力量。
I was green. There were other people there that were a lot more experienced than I was. I was more likely to be out there with hiking boots and long hair and just getting dirty.
我很幼稚。那里有比我经验丰富得多的人。我更可能穿着登山靴，留着长发，弄得脏兮兮的。
So yeah, he was kind of a hippie. But he was a hippie with a degree in biology, who found he was too impatient to spend his adult life in a lab studying the minutiae of wildlife without doing anything to save it. Given the scale of the environmental crisis he saw, science moved too slowly for him.
所以，是的，他算是个嬉皮士。但他是一个拥有生物学学位的嬉皮士，他发现自己太没耐心，无法在实验室里度过余生，研究野生动物的细节，而不做任何拯救它们的事。考虑到他看到的环境危机规模，科学对他来说进展太慢了。
The central message for the Save the Whales campaign was simple-- whales are not commodities. They're living beings. This message was everywhere. There were bumper stickers and T-shirts emblazoned with the words "Save the Whales," the slogan itself becoming so ubiquitous, it was almost cliché, played as a punchline. There were Save the Whales marches and rallies across the world, and Dave was there for all of it.
“拯救鲸鱼”运动的核心信息很简单——鲸鱼不是商品。它们是生命。这个信息无处不在。保险杠贴纸和 T 恤上印着“拯救鲸鱼”的字样，口号本身变得如此普遍，甚至成了陈词滥调，被当作笑话。世界各地都有“拯救鲸鱼”的游行和集会，戴夫都参加了。
Most importantly, he was there in 1982, a pivotal moment in his career, when the International Whaling Commission caved to the pressure and voted to impose a worldwide moratorium on commercial whaling. They'd done it. They'd saved the whales from what many felt was their almost certain extinction.
最重要的是，他参加了 1982 年他职业生涯中的转折时刻，当时国际捕鲸委员会屈服于压力，投票决定对商业捕鲸实施全球禁令。他们做到了。他们从许多人认为的几乎确定的灭绝中拯救了鲸鱼。
So Dave learned two things. One, to succeed, your message had to be everywhere. If your slogan becomes a joke, so be it. At least people are hearing the message. And two, whales are magic. It's that simple. They're just one of those species that people fall in love with.
所以戴夫学到了两件事。第一，要成功，你的信息必须无处不在。如果你的口号变成笑话，那就随它去吧。至少人们听到了。第二，鲸鱼是魔法。就这么简单。它们就是那种人们会爱上的物种。
A decade later, in the '90s, Dave's still in the environmental movement, still advocating for wild whales and attending meetings. And it's at one of these meetings in Glasgow when he gets a call. He's out to dinner with a few colleagues when somebody comes up to the table and says--
十年后的 90 年代，戴夫仍然在环境运动中，仍然为野生鲸鱼奔走并参加会议。就是在格拉斯哥的一次会议上，他接到一个电话。他和几位同事出去吃饭时，有人走到桌边说——
"Is Mr. Phillips here? We have a call for you. Mr. Donner is calling." And I'm like, oh, my goodness, this is Dick Donner calling from Hollywood. Like, what is-- and there's Dick. And he's all in a flutter.
“菲利普斯先生在吗？有您的电话。唐纳先生打来的。”我想，天哪，这是好莱坞的迪克·唐纳打来的。这……然后是迪克。他非常激动。
I haven't introduced you to Dick Donner yet, but I did mention his wife, Lauren Shuler Donner. Together, they were a legit Hollywood power couple, producing or directing blockbusters like The Goonies and Superman.
我还没向你们介绍迪克·唐纳，但我提到过他的妻子，劳伦·舒勒·唐纳。他们是名副其实的好莱坞权势夫妻，制作或导演过《七宝奇谋》和《超人》等大片。
Dick has since passed away, but Lauren told me that they both were self-proclaimed animal lunatics. Dave had actually worked with the couple before. They asked him to consult on a few lines of pro-dolphin dialogue in the buddy cop movie Lethal Weapon 2.
迪克已经去世了，但劳伦告诉我，他们俩都是自称的“动物疯子”。戴夫其实以前和他们合作过。他们请他在搭档警匪片《致命武器 2》中咨询几句关于支持海豚的对白。
Hey, hey. What's that you're eating, Dad?
嘿，嘿。你在吃什么，爸爸？
My tuna fish sandwich.
我的金枪鱼三明治。
Tuna?
金枪鱼？
Daddy, you can't eat tuna.
爸爸，你不能吃金枪鱼。
I can't eat what?
我不能吃什么？
Mom, Dad killed Flipper.
妈妈，爸爸杀了“海豚的故事”。
We're boycotting tuna, honey, because they kill the dolphins that get caught in the nets. Only albacore.
我们抵制金枪鱼，亲爱的，因为他们杀了被困在网里的海豚。只吃长鳍金枪鱼。
Albacore?
长鳍金枪鱼？
It was small, barely a scene, but Dick felt good about it. And now he had something bigger in mind-- Free Willy, a movie he and Lauren were putting together. And Dick wanted Dave's help.
情节很小，几乎不算一出戏，但迪克对此感觉不错。现在他有了更大的想法——《人鱼的童话》，他和劳伦正在制作的电影。迪克想要戴夫的帮助。
And he's like, this movie is going to be big. He's like, it's going to be a great movie. And I'm doing this because I want to make a difference for whales. And I want to know, are you in?
他说，这部电影会大火。他说，这会是一部伟大的电影。我这样做是因为我想为鲸鱼做出改变。我想知道，你加入吗？
The whaling ban Dave had fought for all those years ago protected whales from commercial slaughter, but some species were still captured or killed on a smaller scale. The way Dave saw it, Dick and Lauren were offering him an opportunity to finish the job he'd started all those years ago, a chance to save the rest of the whales.
戴夫多年来争取到的捕鲸禁令保护了鲸鱼免受商业屠杀，但有些物种仍以较小规模被捕获或杀死。在戴夫看来，迪克和劳伦给了他一个机会，去完成他多年前就开始的工作，一个拯救剩余鲸鱼的机会。
Dave and the producers started with something simple-- an 800 number that would pop up on the screen at the end of the movie credits. The idea was that people would call, leave their address, and Dave's organization, Earth Island Institute, would send them a packet of information about the plight of whales across the world, how they could help.
戴夫和制片人从简单的事情开始——在电影结尾字幕处弹出的 800 热线号码。想法是人们会打电话、留下地址，然后戴夫的机构“地球岛研究所”会给他们寄去关于世界各地鲸鱼困境以及他们如何提供帮助的信息包。
The kit was like steps you can take, like, go watch whales in the wild instead of going to watch them in captivity, and put pressure on the International Whaling Commission to stop killing whales.
包里是一些你可以采取的措施，比如去野外看鲸鱼，而不是去圈养地看它们，并向国际捕鲸委员会施压，停止捕杀鲸鱼。
Nothing too elaborate. You called the number, you got a kit. But fast forward a year, and once the movie was released and word got out that the star of Free Willy was sick and still living in a tiny pool in Mexico, well, calling an 800 number and getting a kit just didn't feel like enough. Dave remembers Dick phoning him up again and saying--
没什么太复杂的。你拨打号码，就得到一个包。但快进一年，电影上映后，传出《人鱼的童话》明星生病且仍生活在墨西哥的一个小水池里的消息，拨打 800 号码拿个包似乎不够了。戴夫记得迪克又给他打电话说——
We're being crucified down here. You've got to help us.
我们在这一边快被钉在十字架上了。你必须帮我们。
Now Dick was proposing something far more ambitious, something that honestly sounded a little nuts.
现在迪克提出了更雄心勃勃的事情，听起来确实有点疯。
He said, you've got to get involved in saving Keiko.
他说，你必须参与拯救凯克。
Rescuing Keiko from his life in captivity and releasing him back into the ocean, like in the movie.
像电影里那样，把凯克从圈养生活中解救出来，放归大海。
Did you immediately say, like, this is something I can do, or were you like, this man is crazy?
你当时是立刻说“这是我能做的”，还是觉得“这个人疯了”？
I was like-- it was just dizzying because I'm starting to think, wait, how does this even work?
我觉得……这让人头晕，因为我开始想，等一下，这到底怎么操作？
What fans of the movie wanted was to see their favorite celebrity orca back in the ocean. But that wasn't so simple. First off, nothing quite this ambitious had ever been attempted. True, other captive marine mammals had been released to the wild, but they hadn't been in captivity nearly as long as Keiko.
电影的影迷们想看到他们最喜欢的明星虎鲸回到海洋。但这并不简单。首先，从来没有人尝试过如此雄心勃勃的事情。诚然，其他被圈养的海洋哺乳动物也被放归过野外，但它们被圈养的时间远没有凯克那么长。
So saving Keiko would require an extraordinary effort. Dick Donner wanted Dave to do it, but this wasn't exactly Dave's specialty. His whole career had been focused on big, huge problems, protecting the ocean and saving wild whales, plural.
所以拯救凯克需要非凡的努力。迪克·唐纳想让戴夫去做，但这并不完全是戴夫的专长。他的整个职业生涯都专注于巨大的问题，保护海洋和拯救野生鲸鱼（复数）。
What Dick was proposing in response to the public outcry around the movie was much narrower in scope-- saving the whale, singular. Dave remembers telling Dick Donner essentially, thanks, but I'm not the right guy for this job. But it seems Dick wouldn't take no for an answer.
迪克针对电影引起的公众强烈抗议提出的建议范围要狭窄得多——拯救鲸鱼（单数）。戴夫记得他基本上告诉迪克·唐纳，谢谢，但我不是做这件事的合适人选。但迪克似乎不会接受拒绝。
He was like, nobody else can do this. You have to do this. You've got to do this. The kids are depending on it. Everybody is depending on it. You've got to do this. Will you try?
他说，没人能做这个。你必须做。你必须做。孩子们指望它。每个人都指望它。你必须做。你愿意试试吗？
And there was something about this that resonated. Think of it this way. If you're Dave or an environmentalist of his generation, crazy doesn't necessarily mean impossible. Just a few years before, in 1990, an estimated 200 million people took part in Earth Day celebrations, the most ever by far. This is the decade of the Earth Summit in Rio, the Kyoto Protocol-- big, coordinated global actions to combat climate change and environmental damage.
这其中有些东西引起了共鸣。想想看，如果你是戴夫或者他那一代的环保主义者，疯狂并不一定意味着不可能。就在几年前的 1990 年，估计有 2 亿人参加了地球日庆祝活动，是有史以来最多的一次。这是一个里约地球首脑会议、京都议定书的十年——应对气候变化和环境破坏的大规模协调全球行动。
In 1985, scientists announced that they'd discovered a hole in the ozone layer. And by the '90s, an international treaty was in place to ban some of the chemicals thought to have created it, and it seemed to work. The ozone layer began to heal itself.
1985 年，科学家宣布发现臭氧层空洞。到了 90 年代，一项国际条约已经到位，禁止了一些被认为造成此现象的化学物质，而且似乎奏效了。臭氧层开始自我修复。
Even I remember, and I was just a kid. Those years were my childhood, a time I remember as fundamentally optimistic. We learned about separating our trash in school, reduce, reuse, recycle imprinted on the brain.
连我都记得，我当时只是个孩子。那些年是我的童年，我记得那是一个根本上乐观的时代。我们在学校学习垃圾分类，减少、重用、回收印在脑海里。
We learned about the Amazon and the dangers of climate change, which still felt so far away. We didn't despair because we thought we could still work together to save the planet, that if people just knew what was happening, we'd do the right thing and that the right thing would be clear to all of us.
我们学习亚马逊雨林和气候变化的危险，但那时感觉还很遥远。我们没有绝望，因为我们认为我们仍然可以共同努力拯救地球，如果人们知道发生了什么，我们就会做正确的事，而且正确的事对我们所有人来说都很明确。
That's the moment we're in, the moment Dave's in. And so, sure, saving Keiko sounds a bit nutty, but maybe if you've seen what he's seen, that sort of thing doesn't scare you. So Dave said, OK, I'll check it out. I'll fly down to Mexico City and meet Keiko. He was, if not hopeful, intrigued, until he got there and realized this is a terrible idea.
这就是我们所处的时刻，戴夫所处的时刻。所以，当然，拯救凯克听起来有点疯，但也许如果你见过他所见过的，那种事就不会吓到你。于是戴夫说，好吧，我看看。我会飞到墨西哥城去见凯克。他当时虽然没有充满希望，但很感兴趣，直到他到了那里，意识到这是一个可怕的想法。
By the time Dave visited, Keiko was a teenager and had been living in Mexico City for about 8 and 1/2 years. Dave could see right away, this captive whale was nowhere near ready to live in the ocean. A wild orca can swim over 100 miles a day. Keiko was basically the aquatic equivalent of a couch potato.
戴夫访问时，凯克还是个青少年，已经在墨西哥城生活了大约 8 年半。戴夫一眼就能看出，这头圈养的鲸鱼离野外生活还差得远。野生虎鲸一天可以游 100 多英里。凯克基本上就是沙发土豆的水生版本。
First time I ever went to Mexico to see Keiko, I was completely freaked out. I was sitting up in the bleachers, looking down at this whale in this tiny pool in Mexico City. And he didn't look good. He swam in very small circles. And he could make it across this pool in just a matter of seconds. It was very, very poor facility. I almost started crying, really, to tell you the truth. I was just hit by it, saying, this is just-- this just can't work.
第一次去墨西哥看凯克，我完全被吓到了。我坐在看台上，俯视着墨西哥城这个小水池里的这头鲸鱼。它看起来不太好。它在很小的圈子里游动。它几秒钟就能横跨这个水池。设施非常、非常糟糕。老实说，我差点哭了出来。我被震撼了，心想，这……这根本行不通。
I asked Dave to tick through the reasons Keiko was not an ideal candidate to rewild, and there were many. Before they could even think of releasing him back into the ocean, Keiko needed to get rid of his papillomavirus, but also get stronger, healthier, put on weight. And there was no way he could do that in his current tank at Reino Aventura.
我请戴夫列举凯克不是野化理想候选人的原因，原因有很多。在他们考虑把它放归大海之前，凯克需要摆脱乳头状瘤病毒，还需要变得更强壮、更健康、增加体重。在“冒险王国”目前的池子里，它根本做不到。
And where are we supposed to bring him? We're not bringing him into-- we couldn't bring him into the captive facility. I'm thinking, where are we going to go? We're not going to take him to some place where he's having to perform or be in a captive environment, where they're making money off of these whales. We couldn't do that. So we're going to have to build a place. And that's just a step one.
我们要把它带到哪儿去？我们不能把它带进现有的圈养设施。我想，我们要去哪儿？我们不能带它去那些它必须表演或身处圈养环境、从中盈利的场所。我们不能那样做。所以我们得建一个地方。这仅仅是第一步。
The bill for that alone would probably be millions of dollars, and then they'd have to spend years and millions more teaching him the most basic ocean survival skills and pray that some of those lessons took. Keiko had lived in the care of humans and without his family since he was around two, missing out on years of life in a pod, years of company and hunting and language and what I can only think of as camaraderie, the kind of social environment that makes a killer whale a killer whale.
光是这个账单可能就要数百万美元，然后他们还得花几年时间和数百万美元教它最基础的海洋生存技能，并祈祷其中的一些教训管用。凯克大约两岁起就在人类照看下生活，没有家人，错过了几年在鲸群中的生活、同伴、狩猎、语言，以及我只能认为是友谊的东西，那种让虎鲸成为虎鲸的社会环境。
He had millions of human fans, but not a single orca friend. There were so many things he'd never learned. Not only did Keiko not know how to hunt for food, he didn't know how to eat live fish. Think about that. If you put a live fish in his mouth, this killer whale wouldn't eat it.
它有数百万人类粉丝，却连一个虎鲸朋友都没有。有太多东西它从未学过。凯克不仅不知道如何猎食，它甚至不知道如何吃活鱼。想想看。如果你把一条活鱼放进它嘴里，这头虎鲸甚至不会吃。
And language, Keiko had stopped making most of the sounds in a wild whale's repertoire years before. Pods have different dialects, and it was unlikely Keiko even remembered the dialect he spoke before his capture. This was crucially important to his survival.
还有语言，凯克早在几年前就停止发出野生虎鲸曲库中的大部分声音了。鲸群有不同的方言，凯克很可能甚至不记得它被捕获前说的方言。这对它的生存至关重要。
Orcas very rarely live alone in the open ocean, so if he was to make it out there, Dave knew Keiko would have to be integrated into a pod, his original pod, preferably. But if he didn't speak their language, that was going to be difficult. And then there was the small detail that no one knew for certain which pod that might be, or where to find them-- somewhere in the North Atlantic, near Iceland, presumably.
虎鲸在公海极少独居，所以如果它想在那儿活下去，戴夫知道凯克必须被整合进一个鲸群，最好是它原来的鲸群。但如果它不会说它们的语言，那会很难。还有个细节是，没人确切知道那是哪个鲸群，或者在哪里能找到它们——大概在北大西洋，冰岛附近。
How are we going to get him back to Iceland? It's a whaling nation. Are you kidding me? What, we're going to go over to Iceland and convince them that we want to bring back this whale because the world wants to save him?
我们怎么把它带回冰岛？那是一个捕鲸国。开玩笑吗？什么，我们要去冰岛，说服他们我们要带回这头鲸鱼，因为世界想拯救它？
Did you do a back-of-the-envelope "what's this going to cost" thing on the plane back?
你在返程飞机上做过“这要花多少钱”的粗略计算吗？
Yeah, exactly, before even, while I was down there, and on the way back. I lined it out. I was way over $10 million. And at that point, I pretty much just stashed it back in my pack, saying, I don't know about this. It's just-- we're not used to things with six figures behind it. I can see about 10 impossible steps here.
是的，完全是，还没回来之前，在回来的路上就在算。我列了出来。远超 1000 万美元。那一刻，我基本上把它扔回背包里，说，我不知道这个。这只是……我们不习惯六位数以上的事情。我能看到 10 个不可能的步骤。
So 10 impossible steps, at least. But let's be real. For Dave, it was also one giant opportunity. Up until this point, Dave had been thinking about Keiko the way everyone in the world was thinking about Keiko-- as one individual killer whale in need of saving.
至少 10 个不可能的步骤。但说真的。对戴夫来说，这也是一个巨大的机会。直到此刻，戴夫一直像世界上每个人一样看待凯克——作为一只需要拯救的个体虎鲸。
But what if he allowed himself to see it differently? He'd experienced firsthand the hold that whales had over people at anti-whaling marches across the world. He'd seen the power that media campaigns could wield with the Save the Whales movement. This could be something much bigger. What if Keiko, the individual, could become Keiko the symbol? What if you could use Keiko to tell a story about the ocean itself?
但如果他允许自己以不同的方式看待它呢？他在世界各地的反捕鲸游行中亲身体验过鲸鱼对人们的控制力。他见过媒体运动在“拯救鲸鱼”运动中所发挥的力量。这可能是一件更伟大的事情。如果凯克这个个体能成为凯克的象征呢？如果能利用凯克来讲述一个关于海洋本身的故事呢？
You talk about trying to protect all the oceans and that those are the big issues. Those are the big, huge, unsolvable problems-- global warming, et cetera. But they're so diffuse.
你谈论试图保护所有海洋，那些是大问题。那些是巨大的、无法解决的问题——全球变暖等等。但它们太分散了。
People can't see acidification rising in the oceans. They can't see the coral reefs dying out most of the time. They're not seeing it. It's too broad to say the oceans are dying. There are no grab points. There are no things to manifest what's at risk.
人们看不到海洋酸化的加剧。他们大多数时候看不到珊瑚礁的死亡。他们看不见。说“海洋正在死去”太宽泛了。没有抓手。没有东西可以体现什么是处于危险之中的。
But whales are one of the things that it's just so otherworldly, so majestic, just incredibly, amazingly intelligent, social, powerful. And that means something. It hits people in a different way than talking about the threats to the ocean ecosystems. And then that's what got me over my own view that this is only one whale. It's like, yeah, he's one whale, but he's going to be the most famous or he could be the most famous whale in the world.
但鲸鱼是那种超凡脱俗、极其雄伟、极其聪明、社会化、强大的生物。这意味着什么。它打击人们的方式与谈论对海洋生态系统的威胁不同。这就是让我克服了“这只是一头鲸鱼”这一观点的理由。就像，是的，它是一头鲸鱼，但它将是世界上最有名的鲸鱼。
And Dave knew you could do a lot with that kind of star power, with that kind of attention. So he set aside his doubts and decided that, yes, as absurd as it sounded, he was all in.
戴夫知道有了那种明星效应、那种关注度，你能做很多事情。所以他抛开疑虑，决定，是的，虽然听起来荒谬，但他全力以赴。
Once they've committed to getting Keiko out of Mexico, the next step was logistics. And what I'm about to say is pretty obvious, but it's worth saying anyway-- moving an orca is not easy. One of the first things Dave did was create a whole new organization, the Free Willy Keiko Foundation. The US Humane Society chipped in a million dollars. Dave secured a couple million more from a billionaire cell phone magnate.
一旦承诺把凯克带出墨西哥，下一步就是后勤。我要说的显而易见，但无论如何都值得一说——移动一头虎鲸不容易。戴夫做的第一件事就是创建一个全新的组织，“释放威利凯克基金会”。美国人道协会捐了一百万美元。戴夫从一位亿万富翁手机大亨那里又筹到了几百万。
Warner Brothers also agreed to put in $2 million, which sounds like a lot until you consider they made $150 million on Free Willy. And by this point, the sequel, Free Willy 2, was already in production. Still, with that money, Dave was able to convince a small marine park in Oregon to let the foundation build them a new, much bigger pool just for Keiko.
华纳兄弟也同意投入 200 万美元，这听起来很多，直到你考虑到他们靠《人鱼的童话》赚了 1.5 亿美元。到这时，《人鱼的童话 2》已经在制作中。尽管如此，有了这些钱，戴夫能够说服俄勒冈州的一个小型海洋公园，让基金会为凯克建造一个新的、更大的专用池。
And so now, all Dave needed was the whale, which you might assume would be the hard part, given that Keiko was the main attraction at Reino Aventura. But it turned out that Oscar Porter, the director of Reino Aventura, wasn't opposed to the idea of giving him up. He had a whole park to run, and managing his most famous attraction had become an all-consuming headache. There were journalists and activists to deal with, Mexican television stars and singers calling to arrange private swims with Keiko.
所以现在，戴夫只需要那头鲸鱼，你可能认为这是最难的部分，鉴于凯克是“冒险王国”的头牌。但结果是，“冒险王国”负责人奥斯卡·波特并不反对放弃它的想法。他要管理整个公园，管理他最著名的景点已经变成了一个消耗所有精力的头痛事。有记者和活动家要应付，有墨西哥电视明星和歌手打电话要求安排和凯克的私人游泳。
Porter told me he was spending three hours a day dealing with Keiko-related nonsense-- which is a lot, sure, but most worrying of all was what some of the outside veterinarians were saying, that Keiko might die soon. Porter really didn't want that to happen at Reino Aventura. So over the course of several months, Dave and Oscar Porter made a deal. Reino Aventura agreed to donate Keiko to Dave's foundation for free.
波特告诉我，他每天花三个小时处理与凯克无关紧要的事情——这确实很多，但最令人担心的是一些外部兽医说凯克可能很快会死。波特真的不想那种事发生在“冒险王国”。所以在几个月的时间里，戴夫和奥斯卡·波特达成了协议。“冒险王国”同意免费将凯克捐赠给戴夫的基金会。
Today, we are proud to announce that we have reached agreement on a formal plan, a workable plan.
今天，我们很自豪地宣布，我们已经就一个正式计划，一个可行的计划，达成了一致。
In February 1995, it was announced to the world that Keiko would be leaving Reino Aventura for his new temporary home at an aquarium on the Oregon Coast in an enormous new tank with cold seawater. Dave laid out a vision for Keiko's future, invoking the plot to Free Willy 2, which would hit theaters a few months later.
1995 年 2 月，全世界宣布凯克将离开“冒险王国”，前往俄勒冈海岸一个水族馆的新临时家园，住进一个有着冷海水的巨大新水箱。戴夫为凯克的未来勾勒了愿景，援引了几个月后将在影院上映的《人鱼的童话 2》的情节。
And in that film, Willy is reunited with a mate and has a child and lives happily. This is our goal. We would love to see the situation in which Keiko could have a mate and could be able to eventually be released to the wild.
在那部电影中，威利与伴侣团聚并有了孩子，幸福地生活在一起。这是我们的目标。我们很乐意看到凯克能有一个伴侣，并最终能够放归野外。
Rescue, rehab, release. That was Dave's ultimate plan, even if the last part seemed improbable at best. For Keiko's trainer Renata and many of the staff that worked closely with Keiko, the decision to let him leave was heartbreaking, even if they knew it was the right one.
救援、康复、释放。这是戴夫的终极计划，尽管最后一部分看起来顶多是不可能的。对凯克的训练员雷娜塔和许多与凯克密切合作的员工来说，让它离开的决定令人心碎，即使他们知道这是正确的。
Giving him up was a kind of noble, even maternal, sacrifice. That's how Renata saw it, which, of course, didn't make it hurt any less. Goodbyes are like that, especially when you can't explain what the future holds. You feel guilty, like you're betraying a friend.
放弃它是一种高尚的、甚至是母性的牺牲。雷娜塔是这样看的，这当然不会减轻痛苦。再见就是这样，特别是当你无法解释未来会发生什么时。你会感到内疚，就像背叛了一个朋友。
And across Mexico, a lot of people were feeling this way. They wanted him to stay. They wished he could stay. But letting him go was a sacrifice they were willing to make because they loved him, and they wanted what was best for him. Which is why it was so offensive to Renata and many others I talked to, to hear how the story was being told in the US, that Keiko was being saved from a terrible life in Mexico.
在整个墨西哥，许多人都有这种感觉。他们希望它留下来。他们希望它能留下。但放它走是他们愿意做出的牺牲，因为他们爱它，他们想要对它最好的。这也是为什么雷娜塔和我交谈过的许多人觉得那么冒犯的原因，听到美国是这样讲述这个故事的：凯克是从墨西哥那种可怕的生活中被解救出来的。
Do you feel like there was an element of like, ah, Mexico-- you know how things are down there.
你觉得这里面有种“啊，墨西哥……你知道那边的情况”的意味吗？
Of course.
当然。
Yeah.
是啊。
Of course. It's like, yeah, we have to always help the little brother because he does everything wrong. I'm not saying-- I don't want to say-- that this is the best place for an animal, obviously.
当然。就像，是的，我们总是得帮助小弟弟，因为他什么都做不好。我不是说——我不想说——这对动物来说是最好的地方，很明显。
But I'm trying to say that when he was there, he got a lot of attention. I mean, he got all the attention. We would all the time play. And he would love that, absolutely love that. We did the best we could. We hired the best people. We wanted the best for Keiko. And we donated Keiko without receiving nothing, not one cent in return.
但我想说的是，当它在那儿时，它得到了很多关注。我的意思是，它得到了所有的关注。我们一直玩在一起。它会喜欢那个，绝对喜欢那个。我们尽了最大努力。我们雇了最好的人。我们想要对凯克最好的。而且我们捐赠了凯克，没有收到任何回报，连一分钱都没有。
A few days before Keiko was scheduled to leave Mexico, the Reino Aventura staff threw him one last party, a kind of final spring break bash. Everyone was invited-- current trainers, former staff, all of Keiko's friends, his extended human pod.
凯克预定离开墨西哥的前几天，“冒险王国”的员工为它举行了最后一场聚会，一种最终的春假狂欢。每个人都被邀请了——现在的训练员、前员工、凯克所有的朋友，它的扩大人群鲸群。
So we were like 30 people in this place. And in the dolphinarium, we made a big lunch. And then we all got into the water, and we all played with Keiko. And there was a lot of crying. And I mean, it was fun, and Keiko was so happy. And he would play with all of them.
所以我们 30 个人都在这儿。在海豚馆，我们吃了顿大午餐。然后我们全都下水，和凯克一起玩。有很多人在哭。我的意思是，这很有趣，凯克非常开心。它和他们所有人一起玩。
Wait a second. So you're telling me that 30 people got in the pool with Keiko at the same time to play?
等一下。所以你是说 30 个人同时下水和凯克一起玩？
Yes. Yeah. I mean, you would never get this in SeaWorld or Marineland or any other aquarium in the world. If you tell this to a veterinarian from these huge aquariums, they would tell you that that's not a good idea because, I mean, the animal gets stressed or-- I mean, I don't know what would they say. But he was so happy. He was so happy.
是的。是的。我的意思是，你在海洋世界或 Marineland 或世界上任何其他水族馆都不会看到这个。如果你告诉这些大型水族馆的兽医，他们会告诉你这不是个好主意，因为动物会感到压力，或者……我的意思是，我不知道他们会说什么。但它非常开心。它非常开心。
On January 6, 1996, it was time for Keiko to go. They decided to move him in the middle of the night for a few reasons-- to avoid the heat and the traffic, but also the crowds that were sure to want to say their goodbyes.
1996 年 1 月 6 日，凯克该走了。他们决定在半夜移动它，原因有几个——避开高温和交通，也为了避开那些肯定想告别的人群。
Moving any object as big as a killer whale is an engineering problem, but when that object is a living thing, there's an added complication. Getting Keiko out of Reino Aventura and onto a plane would depend in no small measure on the cooperation of Keiko himself, and that required training. For months, they'd worked on it with him.
移动像虎鲸这样大的物体是一个工程问题，但当那个物体是活物时，就有了额外的复杂性。把凯克从“冒险王国”移出并送上飞机，在很大程度上取决于凯克本人的配合，这需要训练。几个月来，他们一直在和它做这项工作。
First, he'd swim into a small, shallow pool and then into a custom-made sling, swimming in and out of it, weeks spent just getting comfortable with this process. He had to be comfortable because once he was in that sling, he'd stay wrapped in it for at least 14 hours. The challenge would be to keep him calm. He had to trust his humans, not fight or flail. Trust.
首先，它会游进一个小而浅的水池，然后进入特制的吊索，进进出出，花了数周时间才适应这个过程。它必须感到舒适，因为一旦进入吊索，它至少要被裹在里面 14 个小时。挑战在于保持它的平静。它必须信任它的人类，不能战斗或挣扎。信任。
The night of the move, it's noisy and chaotic. I've seen the videos, and it's just manic. It doesn't look like an aquarium or even an amusement park. It looks like a construction site. All this movement and whirring of motors and beeps and shouting and lights. Renata stayed close to Keiko, touching him close to his eyes so he could see her.
移动的那晚，吵闹而混乱。我看过录像，简直疯狂。看起来不像水族馆或游乐园。看起来像个建筑工地。所有的运动、发动机的嗡嗡声、哔哔声、叫喊声和灯光。雷娜塔紧挨着凯克，摸着它靠近眼睛的地方，让它能看到她。
But when it was time for him to swim into the shallow pool where the sling awaited him, he refused, and there was nothing they could do to persuade him. Finally, a dozen people in wetsuits encircled him with a net and pulled him into place. In the shallow pool, Renata and the other trainer dried him off before applying moisturizer all over his body-- actually, the same stuff you might put on a baby to protect from diaper rash.
但当它该游进浅水池，等待吊索时，它拒绝了，他们怎么劝都没用。最后，十二个穿潜水服的人用网围住它，把它拉到位置。在浅水池里，雷娜塔和其他训练员把它擦干，然后在它全身涂抹保湿霜——实际上，就是你可能涂在婴儿身上预防尿布疹的那种。
You need his skin to be protected. So we were rubbing thick, thick cream all over his body. And we would be talking to him the whole time, the whole time. But I was just thinking about him and how nervous he was getting. So he started crying a little bit because he was nervous, and everybody was so nervous. And you can transfer that to Keiko, obviously. So there are moments where you're just hoping that he just relaxes.
你需要保护它的皮肤。所以我们在它全身涂抹厚厚的润肤霜。我们全程都在和它说话，全程。但我只是想着它，想着它变得多紧张。所以它开始哭了一点，因为它很紧张，每个人都那么紧张。而你很明显可以把那种情绪传递给凯克。所以有些时刻你只是希望它能放松。
Once Keiko was in the sling, it was attached to a crane that lifted him out of the pool and placed him in a shipping container filled with 3,000 pounds of fresh water ice. The container sat on the back of a tractor trailer, ready for the hour or so drive across the city to the airport. Once there, it would be loaded onto a giant cargo plane. David convinced UPS to deliver Keiko to Oregon for free.
一旦凯克进入吊索，它就被吊车从水池里吊出来，放在一个装满 3000 磅碎冰的运输箱里。集装箱放在拖拉机的后面，准备进行穿过城市前往机场大约一个小时的车程。到了那里，它会被装上一架巨大的货运飞机。戴夫说服 UPS 免费把凯克送到俄勒冈。
When the caravan finally left, there were crowds, more than they'd expected-- ordinary people who loved this killer whale, whole families, children who dragged their parents out in the middle of the night to say goodbye, all gathered just outside the gates of the Reino Aventura parking lot, so many that police had to move them just so the caravan could pass.
车队离开时，人群聚集，超过了他们的预期——热爱这头虎鲸的普通人，整个家庭，把父母从半夜拖出来告别的孩子，全都聚集在“冒险王国”停车场门外，人数之多以至于警察不得不转移他们，车队才能通过。
And they soon discovered it wasn't just at the gates that the crowds had gathered. It was everywhere. I've talked to a lot of people who were there that night, lining the streets, desperate to say their farewells. One person told me the only thing he could compare it to was the time the Pope visited Mexico City. The route to the airport was supposed to be secret, but that's not how it worked out. Reporters kept the city abreast of the caravan's progress.
他们很快发现人群不仅聚集在门口。到处都是。我和那天晚上在场的人谈过，排在街上，渴望告别。有人告诉我，唯一能与之相比的就是教皇访问墨西哥城的那次。去机场的路线本该是秘密，但事与愿违。记者们让城市随时了解车队的进展。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
There were thousands of people lining the streets--
街上站着成千上万的人——
Keiko! Keiko!
凯克！凯克！
--boys in their pajamas carrying handwritten signs and girls in pigtails carrying Mexican flags, teens shouting and calling Keiko's name. You have to wonder if the whale could hear them chanting, [SPANISH]. "He should stay. He should stay."
——穿着睡衣拿着手写牌子的男孩，梳着马尾辫拿着墨西哥国旗的女孩，十几岁的孩子大声呼喊凯克的名字。你不得不怀疑这头鲸鱼是否能听到他们吟唱 [西班牙语]。 “它应该留下。它应该留下。”
[CHANTING IN SPANISH]
[用西班牙语吟唱]
Then, somewhere along the slow, ponderous route to the airport, there was a mariachi band playing an old song about a loved one's goodbye, "Las Golondrinas." "Where can the tired swallow go?" say the lyrics. "Tossed by the wind with nowhere to hide. Remember my homeland, beloved pilgrim, and cry."
然后，在前往机场缓慢而沉重的路线上，有一个流浪乐团在唱一首关于离别爱人的老歌，“燕子”。“疲惫的燕子能去哪儿？”歌词说。“随风飘荡无处藏身。记住我的家乡，亲爱的朝圣者，然后哭泣。”
[SIRENS WAILING]
[警笛声]
Cars and mopeds follow the procession, drivers waving, honking their horns.
汽车和摩托车跟随车队，司机挥手、鸣笛。
[HORNS HONKING]
[鸣笛声]
Honestly, it's a little bit mad-- the emotion on people's faces, the palpable sense of loss. Dave says some people had to be peeled off Keiko's container as they tried to climb it. The procession just creeps along as best they can, through the impossibly crowded late night streets. A city, a country saying goodbye to its beloved whale.
老实说，这有点疯狂——人们脸上的情绪，那种显而易见的失落感。戴夫说有些人试图爬上凯克的集装箱，不得不被强行拉开。车队在异常拥挤的深夜街道上尽力缓慢移动。一座城市，一个国家，正在告别它心爱的鲸鱼。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
[SINGING IN SPANISH]
[西班牙语演唱]
We would see all these people on the street with signs. I just want to cry just remembering about it. And people waving and crying and screaming goodbye. It was so, so emotional. I was sad and happy at the same time because we're all doing this because we hope he's going to be OK. But it was for Mexicans to say goodbye to the only obviously orca that they would ever have. [SNIFFLES]
我们会看到街上所有那些拿着标语的人。想到这里我就想哭。人们挥手、哭泣、大声告别。这太、太感人了。我既难过又快乐，因为我们做这一切是因为我们希望它会好起来。但这是墨西哥人告别他们唯一可能拥有的虎鲸的方式。[吸鼻子]
The UPS plane carrying Keiko to his new home leaves at around 5:00 in the morning, more than three hours behind schedule, just before a beautiful Mexican sunrise. Only Keiko's veterinarians fly with him. Renata and Dave fly alongside in another aircraft, close enough to see Keiko's plane from their window.
载着凯克前往新家的 UPS 飞机在凌晨 5 点左右起飞，比原定时间晚了三个多小时，就在美丽的墨西哥日出之前。只有凯克的兽医随行。雷娜塔和戴夫飞在另一架飞机上，近到能从窗户看到凯克的飞机。
Keiko no longer belonged to Reino Aventura, and much less to Mexico. He belonged to the story being told about him, the uncertain real-life sequel to the movie that had made him a star, only more far-fetched and with no happy ending assured.
凯克不再属于“冒险王国”，更不属于墨西哥。它属于关于它的故事，那部让它成名的电影的不确定的现实续集，只是更离谱，而且没有保证的快乐结局。
It's kind of funny because it was part of the movie narrative. They were like, how far would you go for a whale? He went as far as raising up his arm and saying some magical words and having Willy jump over the breakwater into freedom. I mean, simplistic, yes, but that's what our narrative was, too. How far could Keiko go?
这有点好笑，因为这是电影叙事的一部分。他们当时就像，你会为一头鲸鱼走多远？他走得远到举起胳膊，说了一些神奇的词，让威利越过防波堤走向自由。我的意思是，简单，是的，但这也是我们的叙事。凯克能走多远？
For the moment, no one knew.
那一刻，没人知道。
Daniel Alarcón, host of the new podcast series, The Good Whale. Of course, as the story unfolds, we hear exactly how far they go to help Keiko. The series is produced by Serial Productions and The New York Times. You can hear episode 2 right now, wherever you get your podcasts.
丹尼尔·阿拉尔孔，新播客系列《好鲸鱼》的主持人。当然，随着故事展开，我们听到了他们为帮助凯克到底走了多远。该系列由 Serial Productions 和《纽约时报》制作。你现在就可以在任何获取播客的地方听到第 2 集。
The New York Times subscribers can hear the entire series right now, including episode 5, which is the episode that is a musical, like an old-school musical from Keiko's point of view, created by the songwriters who did La La Land and Dear Evan Hansen, Benj Pasek and Justin Paul, sung by Jordan Fisher and other actual Broadway stars. Daniel also did a Spanish language version of episode 1 that you can hear on Radio Ambulante.
《纽约时报》订阅用户现在就可以收听全系列，包括第 5 集，那集是音乐剧，就像凯克视角的经典音乐剧，由创作了《爱乐之城》和《致埃文·汉森》的词曲作家本杰·帕塞克和贾斯汀·保罗创作，由乔丹·费舍尔和其他真正的百老汇明星演唱。丹尼尔还录制了第 1 集的西班牙语版本，你可以在《Radio Ambulante》上听到。
Coming up, some other animals get thrown into show business, and they don't seem to be so crazy about it. That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio when our program continues.
接下来，其他一些动物被扔进了演艺圈，它们看起来并不那么喜欢。休息之后，来自芝加哥公共广播电台，节目继续。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today's program, The Truly Incredible Story of Keiko the Killer Whale. We've arrived at Act Two of our program. Act Two, "America's Next Top Gobble."
这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天的节目，“凯克虎鲸不可思议的故事”。我们已经进入节目的第二幕。第二幕，“美国下一个顶级吞咽者”。
So thinking about what kind of story would go with Keiko today, we found this one, also about our dominion over animals' fates. In this case, it's a bunch of birds who are going through months of training for an extremely specific task that is very different from anything they naturally do on their own. Diane Wu has the story.
所以考虑到今天什么样的故事适合和凯克搭配，我们找到了这个，也是关于我们对动物命运的支配权。在这种情况下，这是一群鸟，它们为了一个与它们自然行为完全不同的极其具体的任务，经历了数月的训练。黛安·吴带来了这个故事。
There's this barn in Southeastern Minnesota I want to tell you about. On the outside, it's very plain. It's white, next to a field, smells a little like skunk. But inside, there's this whole project that's been going on for months now.
我想告诉你们明尼苏达州东南部有一个谷仓。在外面，它很普通。白色的，挨着田野，闻起来有点像臭鼬。但在里面，整个项目已经进行了好几个月了。
Should I shut this door?
我要关上这扇门吗？
Yeah, you can.
是的，你可以。
OK. Oh, here they are.
好的。哦，它们在这儿。
Yeah.
是的。
They are turkeys, not just any turkeys.
它们是火鸡，不是普通的火鸡。
Yeah, so this is where we're raising the presidential flock.
是的，所以这就是我们培育总统火鸡群的地方。
[TURKEYS GOBBLING]
[火鸡的咯咯声]
This is the group of birds contending to be the special Thanksgiving turkeys at the White House. Two of them will be selected to go to Washington and be officially pardoned by the president. It's an annual tradition going back decades, organized by the Turkey Lobby. The person showing me around today is John Zimmerman, who's raising these birds, with the help of his shy nine-year-old son, Grant.
这是一群争夺白宫特别感恩节火鸡资格的鸟。其中两只会入选前往华盛顿，并正式受到总统赦免。这是一个延续了几十年的年度传统，由火鸡游说团体组织。今天带我参观的人是约翰·齐默尔曼，他在害羞的九岁儿子格兰特的帮助下培育这些鸟。
Yeah, Grant, this is Diane. Say hi.
是的，格兰特，这是黛安。打个招呼。
Hello.
你好。
Hi.
嗨。
To decide which turkeys make it to the White House, John is basically selecting for the ones that act least like a turkey. He needs two that can stand politely on a special stage while voices boom out over loudspeakers, all in front of hundreds of people-- schoolchildren, photographers, military band. Most commercial turkeys would freak out in this noisy, unfamiliar, unbarn-like environment.
要决定哪些火鸡进入白宫，约翰基本上是在筛选那些表现得最不像火鸡的。他需要两只可以在特殊的舞台上礼貌站立，而声音从扬声器里轰鸣出来的，全都当着成百上千的人的面——小学生、摄影师、军乐队。大多数商业火鸡在这种嘈杂、陌生、不像谷仓的环境中会吓坏。
Well, I mean, turkeys are a prey animal.
好吧，我的意思是，火鸡是猎物动物。
[TURKEYS GOBBLING]
[火鸡的咯咯声]
Their natural instinct is to be afraid of us humans, any other animal, because they would normally be killed and eaten. So--
它们的本能是害怕我们人类、任何其他动物，因为它们通常会被杀死并吃掉。所以——
John's an industry lifer. He grew up on a turkey farm and took over the family business 25 years ago when his dad passed away. Each year, John raises around 140,000 birds in many giant barns.
约翰是行业老手。他在火鸡农场长大，25 年前父亲去世后接手了家族生意。每年，约翰在许多巨大的谷仓里饲养约 14 万只鸟。
These presidential turkeys are a brand new thing for him, though. He's the chairman of the National Turkey Federation. And the way it works is that every year, that's the person who's in charge of raising these presidential turkeys and taking them to the White House.
这些总统火鸡对他来说是全新的。他是全国火鸡联合会的主席。工作方式是，每年那个人都负责培育这些总统火鸡并带它们去白宫。
But being chairman is only a one-year gig. So every chairman is in the situation of being a total novice at training turkeys to be on television, something turkeys have no interest in or talent for at all. And they get exactly one shot to get it right, right in front of the president of the United States.
但担任主席只是一年的活儿。所以每位主席都面临着完全不会训练火鸡上电视的情况，这是火鸡毫无兴趣也毫无天赋的事。而且他们只有一次机会做对，就在美国总统面前。
I don't want to go down in history as the turkey farmer who had a turkey fly in the president's face, or get away, or act in an uncontrollable manner. So I just don't want to have a flappy turkey up there.
我不想作为让火鸡扑在总统脸上、逃走或做出不可控行为的火鸡养殖户载入史册。所以我只是不想在那儿有一只拍打翅膀的火鸡。
He's been watching lots of YouTube videos of previous White House turkey pardonings, trying to anticipate everything that can go wrong. The birds that don't get taken to the White House get put back in with the regular turkeys and then slaughtered. It's an avian Hunger Games in here. And whoever wins will be basically the only two commercial turkeys in America, out of over 200 million raised each year, who get to live.
他一直在看许多 YouTube 上以前白宫火鸡赦免仪式的视频，试图预测所有可能出错的事情。那些没被带到白宫的鸟会被放回普通火鸡群中，然后被屠宰。这里是一场禽类饥饿游戏。而获胜的那两只会是全美每年培育的 2 亿多只火鸡中，仅有的两只活下来的商业火鸡。
So there's you said like 20 birds here?
所以你说这里有大约 20 只？
We've got 29 left.
我们剩下 29 只。
OK. Out of how many did you start with?
好的。你开始时大约有多少？
I started with about 40.
我开始时大约 40 只。
OK. And how did you choose the 11 so far that have been, I guess, deselected?
好的。到目前为止，你是怎么选出那 11 只被筛选掉的？
[CHUCKLES] Yes, one had a scratch on its head. One was kind of flighty, I'll say. When we tried to pick it up, it just didn't want to have anything to do with it. So, I mean, if they weren't as docile as others, we took some out. One was a hen. So when we got them from the hatchery, we wanted all males. Obviously, they missed one. So one was a hen, so obviously she wasn't going to go.
[轻笑] 是的，有一只头上有一道划痕。有一只很轻浮，我会这么说。当我们试图抱起它时，它一点也不想参与。所以，我的意思是，如果它们不如其他鸟乖巧，我们就淘汰了一些。有一只是母的。所以当我们从孵化场得到它们时，我们想要全是公的。显然，他们漏了一只。所以有一只是母的，显然它不会去。
Apparently female turkeys share the same problem as female women in this country, in terms of getting to the White House. The males are the only ones anyone considers because they strut, which, in a turkey, means they puff up their chests, their snoods and waddles turn bright red, and their tail feathers spread out like a peacock's.
显然母火鸡在进入白宫方面遇到了和这个国家的女性同样的问题。公的是唯一有人考虑的，因为它们会炫耀，对火鸡来说，这意味着它们鼓起胸部，肉冠和肉垂变成鲜红色，尾巴羽毛像孔雀一样展开。
By the way, I was surprised to see that all of these turkeys are white, not brown. John tells me it's because brown feathers left dark spots in the skin, which people didn't like. He points over at a turkey with big snood energy.
顺便说一句，我很惊讶地看到所有这些火鸡都是白色的，而不是棕色的。约翰告诉我这是因为棕色羽毛在皮肤上留下了黑点，人们不喜欢。他指着一只“肉冠能量”十足的火鸡。
And he's strutting full bore. He's very dark red on his neck. He's the picturesque Thanksgiving bird right there.
它正全速炫耀。脖子呈深红色。那正是典型的感恩节火鸡形象。
And how do you read his energy? Like, is he feeling aggressive? Is he feeling calm?
你怎么解读它的能量？比如，它感觉好斗？还是感觉冷静？
A lot of it's physiologically looking for a mate. So he's--
很大程度上是生理上在寻找伴侣。所以它……
We both glance at the nine-year-old.
我们俩都瞥了一眼九岁的孩子。
Are you recording right now? He's horny. I mean, that's-- yeah, they're males. They're looking for a mate. They're trying to be the big guy on the beach. That's what they're doing.
你在录音吗？它发情了。我的意思是——是的，它们是雄性的。它们在寻找伴侣。它们想成为沙滩上的大人物。这就是它们在做的。
This kind of strut is exactly what John is hoping two exceptional turkeys can bring to the White House. So he's outfitted the barn into a sort of South Lawn boot camp. He and Grant give me a tour. First, to get the turkeys used to noise and random human voices, John plays the radio for them every day, from dawn to dusk. This is a tip he got from previous chairmen.
这种炫耀正是约翰希望两只出色的火鸡能带到白宫的。所以他把谷仓改装成了一个南草坪训练营。他和格兰特带我参观。首先，为了让火鸡习惯噪音和随机的人类声音，约翰每天从早到晚为它们播放广播。这是他从历任主席那里得到的秘诀。
Alexa, play Power 96.
Alexa，播放 Power 96。
[TURKEYS GOBBLING]
[火鸡的咯咯声]
Grant corrects his dad. Power 96 radio, he's saying.
格兰特纠正了他爸爸。Power 96 电台，他说。
[POP MUSIC PLAYING]
[流行音乐播放]
[TURKEYS GOBBLING]
[火鸡的咯咯声]
Alexa, off.
Alexa，关。
[TURKEYS GOBBLING]
[火鸡的咯咯声]
They don't like the station. They knows what I want. Alexa, off. Alexa, play Power 96 radio.
它们不喜欢这个台。它们知道我想要什么。Alexa，关。Alexa，播放 Power 96 电台。
Playing Power 96.
正在播放 Power 96。
[ROCK MUSIC PLAYING]
[摇滚音乐播放]
We'll go classic rock. They've been raised on classic rock.
我们听经典摇滚。它们是听经典摇滚长大的。
They're not yelling at this one.
它们没对这个尖叫。
Yeah. [LAUGHS]
是的。[笑]
Next, John got this special light off of Amazon, the kind that projects colored patterns onto your house at Christmas.
接下来，约翰从亚马逊买了这个特殊的灯，那种圣诞节投射彩色图案到房子上的那种。
It bothers them a little bit, but that's good. They need to get used to flashing lights from camera flashes and whatnot.
它让它们有点困扰，但这很好。它们需要习惯照相机的闪光灯等等。
Grant marches in with a kid-sized picnic chair and plops it down in the middle of the flock.
格兰特带了一把儿童大小的野餐椅，放在了火鸡群中间。
So another thing we'll do, we'll bring a chair in here and we'll just sit.
所以我们还要做的一件事是，我们带一把椅子进去，然后我们就坐下。
This is to get them used to being around people. John's also enlisted the neighbor kids to come by regularly to sit with the birds and pick them up a lot. At this point, a few weeks out from Thanksgiving, it all comes down to who's hot. The next culling will be for beauty.
这是为了让它们习惯和人在一起。约翰还招募了邻居家的孩子定期来这里坐着，经常抱抱这些鸟。此时，离感恩节还有几周，最终取决于谁最火。下一次筛选将是为了美观。
Obviously, here, we want them to have perfect feathers. So we're really watching their tail feathers and how they fan out.
显然，在这里，我们希望它们有完美的羽毛。所以我们真的在观察它们的尾羽以及它们是如何展开的。
That one looks really full. It's like a full circle.
那一只看起来很丰满。就像一个完整的圆圈。
I see three good choices right there. Three nice tails, yeah.
我看到了三个很好的选择。三个漂亮的尾巴，是的。
Right here in the front?
就在前面吗？
Oh, my.
噢，天哪。
Yeah. [LAUGHS] My problem has been, talking with other chairmen who've gone through this process, they say, oh, you'll be able to pick the best two, no problem, that it will be very easy to pick the final two. Now, maybe in the next week or two, the cream will rise to the top, and we'll find the two that are the best.
是的。[笑] 我的问题是，和其他经历过这个过程的主席交谈，他们说，哦，你选出最好的两只会没问题，选出最后两只会很容易。现在，也许在接下来的一两周内，精华会脱颖而出，我们会找到最好的两只。
But none of them are jumping out to him yet. There's a test John's going to run on the birds soon. He and Grant have built a box to mimic the ones that the turkeys stand on at the South Lawn. And he plans to put each of these birds on the box and see who stays on it the longest. He wants them to hit at least a minute. They did a trial run back in September. He shows me the notes.
但目前还没有哪只让他眼前一亮。约翰很快要对这些鸟进行测试。他和格兰特造了一个箱子来模仿火鸡站在南草坪上的那个。他计划把每只鸟放在箱子上，看谁站得最久。他希望它们至少能坚持一分钟。九月份他们做了一次试运行。他给我看笔记。
This is the team test. So this is how many seconds they were standing on top of the box.
这是团队测试。这是它们站在箱子顶上的秒数。
And so their range is like--
它们的范围大约是……
7 seconds, but then there's a couple--
7 秒，但有几只……
One minute and a half. Two, two minutes.
一分半。两分，两分钟。
Could you do a little demo of that?
你能演示一下吗？
I'll try.
我试试。
OK.
好的。
John goes to get a turkey, and Grant explains how his dad picks it up.
约翰去抓一只火鸡，格兰特解释他爸爸是怎么抱它的。
So you grab the legs, put its belly on the ground, and then put your other hand under its belly.
你抓住腿，让它肚子贴地，然后把另一只手放在它肚子下面。
OK.
好的。
[CHUCKLES]
[轻笑]
[TURKEYS GOBBLING]
[火鸡的咯咯声]
[WINGS FLUTTERING]
[翅膀拍打声]
That one's flapping its wings a bunch. That did not want to get picked up.
那只拍打了很多次翅膀。它根本不想被抱。
He's getting a poor grade. But we'll give him a shot here.
它成绩很差。但我们还是让它试试。
OK, and you set it down.
好的，然后你把它放下。
And now the hope would be that he would just--
现在希望它能只是……
Stand and do nothing. Just "Hi, people."
站着什么都不做。只是“嗨，大家好。”
[TURKEYS GOBBLING]
[火鸡的咯咯声]
What's he doing?
它在干嘛？
He's behaving pretty well. I mean, he's not comfortable. It would be nice if he would just stand here and strut, but he's obviously a little concerned.
它表现还不错。我的意思是，它不舒服。如果它能只是站着炫耀一下会很好，但它显然有点担心。
We watched the bird hunch kind of nervously for 48 seconds. He doesn't strut.
我们看着那只鸟紧张地弓着背 48 秒。它没有炫耀。
The perfect bird would just want to stand here.
完美的鸟只会想站在那儿。
The whole time I'm talking to John, Grant is quietly running around us, inventing chores for himself. He brings in a pumpkin, feeds it to the turkeys, tries to turn on the Christmas lights, keeps picking up different birds, gets a random medal and puts it on one of them, climbs up onto the makeshift stage and squats down, posing as a turkey.
我和约翰交谈时，格兰特一直安静地在我们周围跑来跑去，发明些杂活儿干。他拿来一个南瓜，喂给火鸡，试图打开圣诞灯，不断抱起不同的鸟，弄到一个随便的奖章并戴在其中一只身上，爬上临时舞台蹲下，像火鸡一样姿势。
I get the feeling that he really wants to show me all of this. He's excited to share his turkey project, but is too shy to say much or directly get my attention. John's going to be bringing Grant to the White House, too, later this month.
我觉得他真的很想向我展示这一切。他很兴奋能分享他的火鸡项目，但太害羞而说不出什么，或直接引起我的注意。约翰这个月晚些时候也会带格兰特去白宫。
My son is 9, going on 10, at a shy age. And I expect him to be standing up there with me in front of the cameras. And it is a little bit disconcerting or overwhelming to him. I don't think he's quite aware of what this experience is going to be. So we're training the turkeys, but we're also, in a way, educating and training my son to be part of this event.
我儿子 9 岁，快 10 岁了，正是害羞的年纪。我期待他和我一起站在摄像机前。这对他来说有点令人不安或不知所措。我不认为他完全意识到这次体验会是什么样子。所以我们正在训练火鸡，但某种程度上，我们也在教育和训练我儿子成为这个活动的一部分。
Part of that training is watching past pardoning ceremonies on YouTube together. Part of it is getting him to talk to strangers, like me.
部分训练是和他一起在 YouTube 上观看过去的赦免仪式。部分是让他和陌生人交谈，比如我。
Just getting him used to interacting with adults because he's a nine-year-old boy, and that's not their favorite thing to do always, so.
让他习惯和成年人交流，因为他是个九岁的男孩，这总不是他们最喜欢做的事，所以。
Have you been practicing at all, Grant, for the White House ceremony or thinking about how that'll go for you?
格兰特，你为白宫仪式做过什么准备或者想过会怎么样吗？
Mm, not really.
嗯，没有。
I'm just shy.
我只是害羞。
Are turkeys shy, too?
火鸡也害羞吗？
Um, sort of. Depends on what you do to them. For the most part, I think they are not very shy. If you just stand there, they want to go see, who is this? Who is this? They're only shy if-- probably if you're trying to catch one.
嗯，有点。取决于你对它们做什么。在很大程度上，我认为它们不是很害羞。如果你只是站在那儿，它们想去看看，这是谁？这是谁？它们只有在……可能在你试图抓它们时才害羞。
But usually they're kind of curious and will eventually come up?
但通常它们有点好奇，最终会过来？
Yeah.
是的。
Are you like that, you think?
你觉得你也是那样吗？
Mm-hmm.
嗯哼。
Yeah. It's all about getting acclimated.
是的。这全是为了适应。
John's hoping that at the big press conference, when it's time to announce the turkeys' names, Grant will say them. The week of Thanksgiving, when I watch all of this, that's the part I'm going to be leaning in for-- not to see whether or not the turkey flaps on the box, but Grant's moment to take the stage and strut, if he wants.
约翰希望在大型新闻发布会上，宣布火鸡名字的时候，格兰特会说出名字。感恩节那周，当我看到这一切时，我会倾听那个部分——不是为了看火鸡是否在箱子上扑腾，而是格兰特登台并炫耀的时刻，如果他愿意的话。
Diane Wu is one of the producers of our show.
黛安·吴是我们节目的制作人之一。
["WHALE" BY YELLOW OSTRICH]
Our program was produced today by Sean Cole. The people put together today's show include Phia Bennin, Jendayi Bonds, Michael Comite, Henry Larson, Miki Meek, Katherine Rae Mondo, Stowe Nelson, Ryan Rumery, Lilly Sullivan, Frances Swanson, Christopher Swetala, Matt Tierney, and Julie Whitaker. Our managing editor is Sarah Abdurrahman. Our senior editor is David Kestenbaum. Our executive editor is Emanuele Berry.
今天的节目由肖恩·科尔制作。今天参与制作节目的人包括菲亚·本宁、詹黛伊·邦兹、迈克尔·科米特、亨利·拉尔森、三木·米克、凯瑟琳·雷·蒙多、斯托·尼尔森、瑞安·鲁梅里、莉莉·沙利文、弗朗西斯·斯旺森、克里斯托弗·斯威塔拉、马特·蒂尔尼和朱莉·惠特克。我们的主编是莎拉·阿卜杜拉赫曼。高级编辑是戴维·克斯滕鲍姆。执行编辑是伊曼纽尔·贝里。
Special thanks to Jessica Lussenhop, Michelle Kromm, Peter Gruhl, Marisa Erasmus, and Jason Fields. Serial's new series about Keiko, The Good Whale, was co-reported by Daniel Alarcón and Katie Mingle, produced by Katie and Alissa Shipp. It was edited by Jen Guerra, with help from Julie Snyder, Carlos Lopez Estrada, and myself. Sound design, music supervision, and mixing by Phoebe Wang.
特别感谢杰西卡·卢森霍普、米歇尔·克罗姆、彼得·格鲁尔、玛丽莎·伊拉斯谟和杰森·菲尔兹。关于凯克的 Serial 新系列《好鲸鱼》由丹尼尔·阿拉尔孔和凯蒂·明格尔共同报道，由凯蒂和阿丽莎·希普制作。由珍·格拉编辑，朱莉·斯奈德、卡洛斯·洛佩兹·埃斯特拉达和我本人提供了帮助。声音设计、音乐指导和混音由菲比·王完成。
Original score from La Chica and Hausmane. The song "Las Golondrinas" was performed by Mariachi Hidalgo NYC. Research and fact-checking by Jane Ackermann, with help from Ben Phelan. Other people who put together The Good Whale include Ndeye Thiobou, Mack Miller, Liz Davis Moorer, Susan Wessling, Al-Amyn Sumar, and Simone Procas.
原创配乐来自 La Chica 和 Hausmane。歌曲“燕子”由 Mariachi Hidalgo NYC 表演。研究和事实核查由简·阿克曼完成，本·费伦提供了帮助。其他参与制作《好鲸鱼》的人包括恩德耶·蒂奥布、麦克·米勒、利兹·戴维斯·穆勒、苏珊·韦斯林、阿尔-阿明·苏马尔和西蒙娜·普罗卡斯。
This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange. A note to our This American Life Partners-- We just released a bonus episode that is a conversation about some very fun, very old stories with producer Zoe Chace. So check your feeds for that.
《美国生活》由公共广播交流平台 PRX 发送给公共广播电台。致我们《美国生活》合作伙伴的通知——我们刚刚发布了一集奖励节目，是关于一些非常有趣、非常古老的故事的对话，由制作人佐伊·查斯主持。所以请检查你们的订阅源。
To everybody else, to become a Life Partner and get bonus content, ad-free listening, AMAs, and other stuff, go to thisamericanlife.org/lifepartners. The link is also in the show notes of this episode.
对其他人，要成为生活合作伙伴并获得奖励内容、无广告收听、问答环节及其他内容，请访问 thisamericanlife.org/lifepartners。链接也在本集的节目笔记中。
Thanks, as always, to our program's confounder, Mr. Torey Malatia. He knows his name pops up in my cell phone every time he calls, but still, he opens every single conversation the same way every single time--
一如既往地感谢我们节目的联合创始人，托雷·马拉蒂亚先生。他知道每次他打电话时他的名字都会在我的手机上弹出，但他依然每次都以同样的方式开始每一场对话——
This is Dick Donner calling from Hollywood.
这是好莱坞的迪克·唐纳打来的。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带回更多《美国生活》的故事。
["WHALE" BY YELLOW OSTRICH]